And three, two, one.
Cold open.
Hey, it's podcast time, everybody.
Welcome, welcome.
You're live on podcast time.
We're cold opening.
Yeah, we're.
We're getting ready to do our little show.
I hope you stick around for that instead of just this.
Yeah, you get ready to listen.
We'll get ready to talk.
Ready, set, go.
Welcome to Smartless.
I'm going full tilt this morning.
It's a smartless.
It's one of our OG original ones.
Smartless, howdy?
You're cool dad this morning.
Did I tell you?
So the other day, I've never wanted it out of the house, obviously, for every...
Yeah, you don't want people to know that.
Well, also, it's got our faces on the back.
Yeah, you don't want to be like, hey, hey, Johnny wearing his merch.
So the other day, wearing the house, went to do my little walk that you guys know, and forgot that I had it on.
And then my shirt, and I had to wear it to go, and I went to Whole Foods.
And I realized as I was getting out of the carto...
Why'd you have to wear it?
Because if you took it off, you'd be just in a sweaty...
Well, I'd taken my t-shirt off because it was gone.
It was so soaked in sweat because I work out so hard.
Because if you want to, let me walk you through the workout.
Well, because you're wearing the heavy hands.
You strap on the heavy hands and the heavy ankles, right?
The Velcro.
And I got the big visor that comes down in front and then I got the locked up.
No, because I'm wearing the, you know, I got the weight vest, as we know.
So you're shirtless with a hoodie on.
So anyway, shirtless with the hoodie on.
And then I'm in line.
Smartless hoodie on in holtoots.
Oh, God.
I hope you're in and up.
somebody you know.
No, I got a guy, I forget the news name.
He always does, like, Getty Images, photos at events.
And he's like, and I just hear it.
I was like, well, it looks like somebody's got Will Arnett on the backwards.
And I turn around with him.
And I go, luckily, we all kind of know.
I forget his name is a nice guy.
And I was like, oh, shit, at which point.
And then I go up to, I do a self-checkout.
And this girl taps me on their shoulder.
They're like, are you willing to go?
Yeah, and I'm like, really big fan.
And I was like, and I literally said to the stranger, and I said to the stranger, and I
said to this stranger, I was so embarrassed.
I go, by the way, I never normally would wear this, but I didn't have to.
God, it gets worse.
And I just ran to my car.
I was like, what a tool.
It a deeper sweat.
Then I hope you were locked out of your car, had to call AAA on the side of the road.
Standing on the center of the street.
I'll wear smartless sweats.
No, we know.
No, to the gym, to the gym.
I know.
Sure.
Or anyway.
But nobody cares.
Nobody stopped.
It was so humiliated, tapped on the shoulder.
I love the show.
Excuse me, are you Will or net?
Yeah, how's your merch going?
Wait, what's that new tag for Reesis's?
Where you're using the Reesies name for a different word?
Like, it's all, instead of like it's all reality, it's all Reesies, or something like that?
I don't know.
I was impressed with it this weekend.
Yeah, everybody loves the Reeses?
No.
And something like that.
That was exciting.
You were expecting more from that?
I apologize, I'm picking my teeth a little bit.
What is, what, what's the, what's the, don't start now?
What's the protocol?
Yeah, I know.
Yeah, the politeness thing.
You guys aren't, aren't both real deep on manners, but I wouldn't mind pulling.
Much more than you are.
I don't know about that.
Yeah.
What about, about, I don't talk about potty stuff.
I don't, I don't, you don't, you don't, you don't fart.
You don't fart either.
Yeah, of course.
I don't think you've ever farted in front of me.
Well, it's disgusting.
Who wants to hear?
What are you talking about, man?
Oh, listen, that's just, it's just dude shit, you know, bro.
Not just dude shoes.
I mean, Sean and I love our power burps.
Sean, I think you and I, I've definitely farted in front of you, Sean.
I think you've definitely farted on me.
Yeah, you've farted in front of me before.
I have, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And the car.
But Willie doesn't.
He doesn't.
So then Will, then you don't, you don't, you don't, did you ever poo in front of, um, Amy?
Are you looking for clicks?
No, I'm just saying.
Are you trying to get something that we can click around?
Always forget people listening to this.
Wait, but hang on, you were married to her, had two kids, you guys never went to the bathroom in front of each other?
I'm sorry, the question is, did I poo in front of Amy?
And you're saying that I don't have manners?
What are you talking about?
It's a good question. It's not a good question. I refuse to answer it.
It's a cute question.
I refuse to answer that.
Did you poo?
Yeah.
All right.
I hope we have a very respectable guest on.
Well, let me ask you.
We do, and she's going to be outraged by this, by the way.
But wait a minute.
But wait a minute, do you poo in front of Amanda?
I mean, we don't use the same potty, but...
Potty, God, if she needed to come in and ask me...
If she needed to come in and ask me something important, she could and would.
I don't know if I would do that to her, although to hear her, she doesn't poo.
Never has.
Right.
I don't know how...
It's amazing.
But, yeah.
Yeah.
I spoke to her this morning.
She said, please tell him that I'm jealous that we get to see your face and she didn't this morning.
Oh, that's your age.
It's coming up on three weeks.
I know.
When are you back?
We saw her this weekend.
I talked to her yesterday and I saw her Saturday night.
Yeah, we saw her Saturday.
I've been spending a lot of time with her.
Yeah, same.
Yeah.
Well, let me say this.
get home, she is worn out.
Just give her a break.
I love, can I just say all, all bits aside,
how much I do love your wife Amanda.
We all do a job.
We all love it.
I was on the phone with her this morning.
She's the fucking greatest.
She's such a good friend.
She's so thoughtful and kind and sweet.
Always available.
Yeah, she's amazing.
I like her too, pretty much.
She's so, so good.
Tell you's good.
It's always real good.
class in, you're going to feel badly about all this
disgusting potty talking. Tell me she's not an
award winner, is she? Oh, well, okay,
well, tell me if this means a lot.
Uh-oh.
Ten Golden Globe nominations
and two wins. Wow.
Seven BAFTA nominations.
Oh, I was going to say, does she have a British accent?
Two Emmy Noms.
Ten Sags
nominations and two wins.
I apologize.
Five Academy Award
nominations. Wow.
Christ.
Five Academy Award
nominations.
Do you like films like
Junebug. Do you like films like Night of the Museum?
Julian Julia?
Do you like the master, the Muppets,
on the road? Arrival, Sean.
Oh my God.
Okay, Nightbatch.
She's fine with the poo talk.
Get around here.
Hi.
I'm so glad I entered on this conversation.
I'm so embarrassed, Amy.
I'm sorry.
No, no, don't be.
We know each other a little.
I know you're good with the poo talk.
I'm fine with poop talk.
Absolutely. And I also love Amanda.
Yeah, she's the best.
Oh, my gosh.
How nice you're here with us, Amy?
I'm so happy to be here.
Yes, I'm very glad to get to participate in this conversation.
Important conversation.
Well, jump in if you want.
Yeah, sure.
Welcome.
Here's our new intro.
Pretend that it never happened.
Now we get the...
Guys, it's Amy.
Hi.
Hi, guys.
Amy, where are we finding you today, by the way?
I'm really liking your background.
Los Angeles in my kitchen.
Okay, in your kitchen.
So nice.
Yeah.
Amy, I'm going to let Will drive this,
but I'm dying to get to doubt.
Don't worry, he won't.
And arrival,
because those are two of my favorite films ever.
And I've seen Arrival probably,
no joke, probably like 10, 12 times.
It's so good.
Amy, I can't tell you how many times
we've had other people on
who have no connection to a rival
and then China B.
Have you seen a rival?
Yeah.
But that script is one of, you know,
not since like, you know,
the sixth sense or something.
Have you read a script or seen a script or seen a movie, whatever,
that has an ending that just completely blows your mind.
I mean, the fact that all the flashbacks were actually flashed forwards is so...
Spoilerly.
You've never seen anything like...
Like, when you read it, were you like, wait a minute, what?
Yeah, I mean, I was reading it sort of thinking it was told in like a traditional timeline,
so I still loved it.
But then when I got to the end, I was like, oh, no, I got to go back and reread it and understand it in a different way.
You almost have to watch the movie again.
Yeah, it's, it was so crazy to shoot it because I had to perform it as if it were, like, it was I had to live in those, in that duality of like letting the audience think that it was flashbacks.
But then on a rewatch, understanding that it was a flash forward.
So that was a lot of fun to play with.
So smart.
Yeah, that's so smart.
Yeah, Denise's amazing.
He's so good.
That guy is so good.
And he's lovely.
He's like the nicest.
He was on the podcast, yeah.
Oh, isn't he just like so humble and funny?
and you're like, yeah.
Can you imagine he had to deal with Sean
that whole, the whole podcast?
It was just, it was such a handful.
I was dripping sweat.
And then you did, and then you did the, and then you, and you're like,
and Dune, I'm like, Dune.
Yeah.
And then I was the idiot over here calling him Denny the whole time, which is Dennis.
That's all right.
I called him Dennis Villanueva, so there you go.
Villanueva.
Oh, no.
Not to him.
I joke to him because that's kind of how it's spelled in sort of the.
Right.
Well.
Colorado, pronoun.
But I was going to say in Colorado, by way of, so I didn't know this, that you were born in Italy.
I was born in Italy.
Which part?
Dad was in the Army.
My dad was stationed at Vicenza and Aviano Air Force Base, and Vicenza Army Base.
So I was born in that region, which is kind of in between Florence and Venice.
Scotty, my husband, Scotty, he's in Army Bratt, too.
He was born in Okinawa, Japan.
Oh, wow.
Yeah, so you guys are like born all over the world.
Exactly.
My husband was born in Ramstein, Germany.
Oh, wow.
Also, also, also, also, parents in the...
Also, Air Force, yeah.
Also Air Force?
Yeah, his dad was Air Force, so...
Oh, wow, that's cool.
Then how does it work then to get an American passport?
Do you have to, like, sort of, when you come to this country, then what goes on with that?
Well, her parents are American.
So she's an American born to Brun.
You're naturalized.
Because you're born on an American base, yeah.
Exactly.
Yeah.
Can you run for president?
I think I'm I don't think that's in my interest okay I think technically I mean by the way all the rules are at the window on that one I think so are there any rules do that anymore I think I'd be I'd be great I bet you'd be very good yeah I bet you be very good I'd vote for you there'd be a lot of singing in the white house that's for sure yeah that would be lovely so so you're you're born overseas to air force dad and he moved around a
Army Dad. Oh, sorry.
My husband has an Air Force Dad.
Sorry, I'm not that particular, but just in case he is.
I want to.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, of course.
Of course.
Okay, so Army Dad.
Yeah.
And then you end up basically settling in Colorado, which you mentioned.
Yes.
And then where did the sort of the interest come from to, you know, for performing?
Because you're not just a great performer who does it at the highest level.
You're also prolific.
You've done so much.
And so it seems like, where does that come from?
Was your mom into that or was your dad into that?
Were they encouraging?
My dad was a performer.
Oh, wow.
He played, he had a band and sang,
and he ended up being sort of like a one-man band,
and he played in bars,
and so we'd go watch him in bars.
Wait, wait, with the symbols tied to the leg and everything.
It wasn't quite Dick Van Dyke, Mary Poppins.
I love that.
No, he had like all.
these synths and he would like push buttons for, yeah.
Bang your knees together for the symbol hit.
Yeah, at pizza joints, just walking around, flapping his wings.
Oh, I love that.
They'd just turn them loose for someone's birthday coming out of the kitchen.
I actually wish that's what he did.
That would be great.
No, he would play, there's a foot synthesizer, right?
So I don't know if you guys have ever seen those.
Yeah.
So you would wear fancy socks.
play the foot synthesizer.
Come on.
Kind of like big, like the movie Big.
No, it's a...
No.
Isn't it?
It's not like that.
It's literally looks sort of like...
I guess this is what came to mind.
You know in Goonies, that big piano?
Yeah.
That they play with the skeleton bones.
It's like that, but like black.
Blacker.
I don't know.
That's the best way.
That's the visualization that came...
Is it kind of like the bottom path of an organ?
Like when they push the feet with you.
Yeah, exactly.
So he pushes on these pedals with his feet while he plays.
You saved it, John.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Thank you for that.
I'm like, it's kind of like the goonies skeleton.
I'm like, imagine if they made big and goonies?
And you're like, imagine if Steve Villeneuve made like goonies and big?
And the person who's making it as watching a rival?
Wait, so, Amy, this doesn't sound like an army dad.
I'm just like, return to the goondocks.
All of a sudden, you guys, I'm writing a script to say.
Right.
Yeah, you're right.
Jason's right.
It doesn't sound like a regular army dad.
He can also clean a weapon, too.
I mean, this guy's multi-talented, we're saying.
You're painting a great dynamic picture.
Absolutely.
Yeah?
Yeah, but mostly played music.
Wow.
So then that's where you got your...
So then did singing and dancing precede acting?
Yes, yeah.
Absolutely.
I never thought I was going to be an actress.
I was such a musical theater kid and mostly trained in ballet, but like I was so shy.
And I had paralyzing stage fright.
Really?
But I make myself do it anyway.
And every time I'm like, why do I do this to myself?
Yeah, it's torture.
But isn't stage fright more acute on a stage doing, singing, dancing, spotlight, microphone.
It's not cute anywhere.
Isn't the fright more intense there than in front of a camera or no?
Yes.
Oh, yeah.
I mean, they still get nervous in front of a camera, but it's such an intimate thing.
And you have one person you can focus on.
And you can screw up.
You can screw up, exactly.
Yeah, and then just do it again.
Now, this is reminding me because I was doing a project.
This is many, many, many, many, many years ago.
Oh, which project was this?
Buckle up.
Sorry, which project were you working on?
I can't say.
No, that's all.
I will applaud.
Go ahead.
And the producers were like, you should reach out to Amy Adams for this project.
And I was like, well, I don't know Amy Adams.
I'm a big fan, but I don't know.
No, just do what she knows you're going to call.
So I called you.
I don't know if you remember this.
I called you, and you picked up, and you go, hello.
And I go, hi, Amy, it's Sean.
Hayes, oh, I'm in the White House right now in the bathroom. Can I call you back?
Do you remember this?
I was at the White House for Julie and Julia.
Oh, my God.
And that's when I was like, wait, the time I call you, you're in the bathroom at the White House.
Yes, I was in the bathroom at the White House.
That is crazy.
So that was last time you talked to her?
Yeah, that was last time you talked to her.
Yeah, that was last time I talked to Amy. Have you been since?
You know, just hanging out.
Wait, wait, so Amy.
Having a kid.
But what I want to know, oh, yeah, we're going to get into that.
But what I want to know is you didn't think you would have a career as an actor.
So, and your dad's doing all these, playing the one-man band in the bars and stuff.
How do you go from that to what's your first acting gig?
And how did that happen?
From Colorado.
Well, I started dancing.
That was sort of my way into performing, which was good because I could be with, like, a group of people.
For me, it's very much about a singular focus.
So, like, always being in the chorus was really fun because you got to feed off of everybody else
and just become a part of a group, you know.
Yeah, right.
And I love that.
So, yeah, I got into dancing, which led me after high school.
I was going to say the reason I got into all of it
is because I was bad at math because I wanted to be a doctor.
So I was like, really?
Really?
What kind of doctor?
Still wish I could have been a doctor.
I think I wanted to work in emergency medicine.
I'm really good in a crisis.
Yeah.
Really?
And you'd be okay with like blood and gore and like somebody in a lot of pain.
Yeah, yeah.
trauma you'd be okay with?
I really, I want to like,
I have this fantasy that when I retire
from acting, I'm going to be one of the seniors
that volunteers down at Cedars.
I was like, I kind of have the same thing.
Do you?
I kind of want to, yeah, like, I want to just go, like,
help people out, like, what's going on?
Well, you're going to be there anyway, so you might as well.
You've got your own parking spot there.
It's a hop, skip and jump.
Wait, that's so interesting.
Are you good?
So, so, because some people are like,
flight instead of fight
during emergencies, right?
They're like, I can't deal with this and they run away.
Whereas, like, there's this one time when I was driving home from a taping of Will and Grace
and a guy was lying in the middle of the street.
This is a sitcom.
So funny.
So many misunderstandings.
They don't make them.
They don't make them no more.
They're not like that.
Not with the laughs.
And this one thinks this.
And the other one thinks this.
And they have a misunderstanding.
They have a misunderstanding.
The one door shots.
The other one.
in no analysis in one bed.
Everybody's gay.
Funny.
Sorry, Amy.
Sorry about that.
No, I love it.
I love it.
You guys are great.
I'm like sometimes way too earnest,
so I appreciate you guys bringing humorous.
We're not.
We should be, we should learn from you.
No, exactly.
No.
No, so I was driving home from one of the tables
and there's this guy lying in the middle of the street
and I was like, what?
And the two cars ahead of me were just driving around him.
I was like, what?
But this guy's lying in the middle street.
That was me and well.
On the gas.
Smart.
Just missed his head.
And so I pull over as somebody would do.
And then just as I open the door to my car, I'm like, oh, is this one of those things,
this setup where I get out, I help the guy, and then somebody takes my car or whatever,
or, you know, jumps me or whatever it is.
So then...
I'd love to see you get taken over by that guy.
I'd rather do the tidying behind the mailbox.
And them just taking your car and your clothes.
By the way.
And just leaving you.
Them tying you up and them not understanding how much you're enjoying it.
And I'm just going, no, stop.
No, ouch.
You don't want these clothes?
Oh, good.
You don't want these.
No, wait.
What?
How am I going to get home naked?
You'll figure it out.
Okay.
It's crazy.
All right, so, oh, my God.
So you end up lying in the middle of the road so somebody pulls over it for you.
It's a cycle.
Because now you need a ride.
Sorry, Amy.
So, Amy.
It's okay.
I love it.
You know, I love it.
You're kidding.
I was only a few blocks from home, too.
Yeah.
Oh, God.
We'll be right back.
And now, back to the show.
All right, so.
So you're about to get out of the car.
You think it might be a thing.
But then I was like, but the guy could see us in real pain.
God, this is a long way to go to get to the question.
But I, so I get out, and the guy just got shot.
The guy was shot.
Oh, yeah.
And so I did take off my shirt, and I put, I didn't know what I was doing.
like to your point, like emergencies, like, you know, fight or flight.
So I was like, I know, I'm going to do this.
So nobody was around.
And so I took my shirt off.
I put it on the bullet wound on his stomach.
And I was like, hold it over for some pressure, not a turn to it or anything.
Correct.
Well, yeah, a makeshift turning around.
And so I'm telling on 9-1-1 on my phone.
Meanwhile, other people have heard it and now are starting to coming out of their houses, right?
And so they already called too.
And then-
You starting to feel self-conscious about being topless?
A little bit, a little bit, a little bit.
Were you actually topless?
I was, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And so I...
Not everyone wears a undershirt, granddad.
Yeah, go ahead.
And so, yeah, so the guy, I don't know, that's...
So, finally, the ambulance came and everything, and he lived and he was okay, and everything
was fine.
He got the help he needed.
And, but, but, of course, the ambulance guy was like, are you, Shawnee?
No.
With my hand on his stomach.
I was like, yeah.
But anyway, the point is...
Still topless.
And then we exchange numbers.
No, I'm kidding.
But the point is, yes.
Emergencies, I attack them.
I don't run from them usually.
Yeah, I get very focused.
Like, everything becomes very focused in an emergency.
I'm sorry.
Was that whole story about the time that you saved the dude's life?
Yeah.
Just to prove that he runs into a fire instead of away from a fire.
Yeah, yeah, for sure.
Yeah.
I've come across a couple of scenes where we've been sort of the first people on the scene.
Oh, really?
Really?
Yeah.
Care to share?
Like where?
We were in Santa Monica and coming out of our favorite restaurant.
And I was with my dad.
And my dad is also very much like that, thankfully.
And these people were screaming and a guy was walking and they're yelling, he's dying.
And my husband's like, that's blood.
And I was like, Darren, you stay here with our daughter.
We ran over and he'd been stabbed in the neck.
Oh, gosh.
Yeah.
So he was bleeding and his friends were freaking out.
So luckily we're going to the beach.
We grabbed towels.
my dad has been on lots of scenes.
I guess he attracts them as well and applied pressure.
And I'm sitting there somehow going,
you need to calm your pulse rate, take a deep breath.
Wow.
I was just so focused.
I was like, the more you struggle,
the faster you're going to bleed, just lay down.
Let's elevate this.
We were like just, and yeah.
And then I ran into him a year later.
A guy walks up to me in the restaurant.
He's like, I heard a story that you and your dad
were on the scene of a guy getting stabbed.
And I was like, yeah, yeah, that's so funny.
You heard that story, and he went like that.
And I was him.
Oh, my God, it's you.
And it was him.
No, wow.
Yeah, it was him.
And he was like all teary
and he had his son with him.
Wow.
Yeah, it was so crazy.
Did he tell you what the situation was
under which the reason that he got stabbed?
I mean, as far as I could make out,
it was, they had run into an old college friend
and had some drinks and then went to the liquor store.
They were going to go back to someone's house
and he just freaked out.
But I don't know kind of what
the whole story.
Wow, wow, wow.
That's crazy.
Yeah.
Would have been great if you and your dad
started singing him a little song to calm him down.
Oh, yeah, like a one-man.
Yeah.
You had like a little pocket trombone or something.
Can you imagine I just start singing like Jezelle.
Well, your dad's, and you're dancing.
I'm like, stay away.
That's calming, you know.
That is calming.
Just start singing Mary Poppins.
That would have been nice.
Wow, you really would have been great in an emergency room.
I'm not that smart, but I'm that focused.
You're not smarter than we are.
No, I don't think so.
Have you ever played a medical person?
You know, I did in Dr. Vegas.
I played Rob Lowe's.
Wait a second.
All right.
I need to see this.
Yeah, me too.
And so I went and...
What year did we make this?
2001.
Actually, it's a good thing.
good story. I was filming and they sent me home and I was mad because I was like, of course,
the one project where you want to stay where they're filming in Vegas when I was like, you know,
30. And when I went home, I got the Junebug audition. And then was filming Junebug when they
reduced my role from, to recurring.
Oh, he's bad. On TV show. On Dr. Vegas. And I was like, I'm good. They're like, you're just going
leave. I'm like, yeah, I'm good.
I'm all set. I've got an indie.
Suck it. I just did an indie.
I'm set. I'm just going to go ahead and get
an Academy Award nomination over here, so I'm good.
You want to reduce it?
Yeah.
I had no idea. I just was like,
anyway, it's a long story, but I did
shadow an emergency room doctor.
Before that part, yeah. Yeah. And I was like,
yeah, yeah, yeah. That's got to be fascinating.
Did you not want to see? Did you see some things you didn't want to see?
I think for me, I was just
fascinated with the stories that kind of really helped me put things into perspective. I know. I'm so
earnest. I told you guys. I just was so grateful and invested in people's personal stories. It's just
I was at, you know, I'm a frequent flyer at the ER in Los Angeles. But you want to give a shout
out to Cedarsford? Do you get a discount? Yeah, Cedar Sine. Yeah. And I was lying there waiting to get
extra couple of punches on your punch card. You'd get to your bonus earlier.
for the cafeteria.
Sean's nickname is Paddles, by the way.
This is true, Amy.
Because I get AFib and they zap my heart back.
Anyway, but one time I was in there,
this was like two years ago,
and the guy, some guy, OD'd on drugs,
they were trying to revive him,
and he died right next to me in the room right next to me.
It's so crazy to witness all that.
Willie and I play golf with Dr. Gary Shalman.
He does an ER doctor,
and the things that he knows,
had a do, and he could save any life you put in front of him.
I think it's incredible.
Yeah, it's really amazing.
And he's got a great short game, too.
You can get up and down from anywhere, really.
By the way, let's be clear, he's got a great game all around.
He's middle of the fair way.
Long game, yeah.
I never see him in trouble.
He never see him looking for a ball.
Never.
You want him as your teammate.
Yeah, Dr. Gary's been playing with the same ball for three years, definitely.
Anyway, let's ask him.
Shout out to Dr. Gary.
You know, so, Amy, you've done so many things,
but so many different kinds of roles, like comedy, drama, sci-fi.
Is there one I've seen the most is enchantment?
Enchanted?
Or enchanted.
You nailed it.
You never saw enchantment because it doesn't exist.
Yeah, I mean, you know, having two girls, you met both of them.
Yeah, how are they doing?
They must be.
They're doing great.
Thanks, yeah.
They're not watching it anymore.
Yeah, but I mean, I knew that album backwards and forwards.
Loved it.
Thank you, and I'm sorry.
Yeah, no, no, no.
It was fantastic.
But I've seen them all, but that one a lot.
I bet, yeah.
Yeah, very good.
Thank you.
Do you have, do you have like a genre that you like doing more than,
because you kind of, you've done, like I said, you've done it all.
Like you do, you work in comedy, you work in drama, you work in sci-fi.
Like, is there one sort of lane that you feel more comfortable in?
Or do you just kind of, each one?
is just like a new opportunity to have fun and you don't really think about it.
Yeah, I think each one's a new opportunity.
I like working in different genres because it requires like a different approach to tone and it's a challenge.
But I mean, I'm most comfortable in like musical theater even at 51 if someone's like,
you need to go play Bell.
I'd be like, got it.
Like that's like, that's where my like spirit lives.
My like younger, my inner child.
Do you want to do more of it?
I do.
I did theater recently in the same.
London, and I really do want to do more of it, but I think I'm so tired all this time.
It's so much work. I have so much respect for everybody who works on stage because doing that
age shows a week is really, really grueling. And so I'd have to really consider it. Maybe when my
daughter is a little older. Gets little when she's out of the house because I really want to be
present for her. How old is she? She's going to be 16 next Friday. Oh, wow. Yeah. That's amazing,
I know. How are those driving lessons going?
She has not started them yet.
No.
You haven't taken her out in your car and just like in an open parking lot and said, and just put her in the seat?
Not yet.
No.
I am definitely, she has absolutely.
No interest.
No, she has interest.
But she wants to get through finals before she starts studying for her permits test because she.
Yeah.
Disciplined.
That's disciplined.
Yeah, but this generation, though, is because of Uber.
There's just, there's no.
That's true.
I didn't think of that.
When we were kids, remember, like, the day?
The morning you turn 16, you're at the DMV.
No, my guys did.
Arch got it immediately, but Abe's been kind of putting it.
Well, he can only get his learners because he's not 16 yet.
You know what I thought would never happen, though, is that because Jason's right, when you turn 16, you're like, it signifies independence driving, right?
Freeing.
But now, and I thought, well, that will never go away, but with Waymo self-driving cars and Uber and stuff, maybe it's not a thing anymore.
I don't know with kids.
Yeah, but it is nice to be able to just like walk outside your house
and climb into your car and go.
It is.
I think she's really going to love that sensation
when she sort of gets into it,
but I respect, I'm letting her...
Are you still in driving her around mode,
or is she leaning on the UBS like everybody?
A little of both.
I mean, we're a little more cautious with Ubers
as long as she's with friends and stuff like that.
But she loves a Waymo.
That's her thing.
Yeah, we always say it's a known thing, Amy.
that Jason has the personality of a Waymo driver.
That's just kind of known around the office here.
Just around the office here.
A Waymo driver.
That's enough, Sean.
So funny.
By the way, by the way, I was going to save this.
Sean, I think you know this,
and you're going to freak out again on Amy.
You know, she's in the new,
she just wrapped the new Star Wars.
right.
What do you mean?
The one with Ryan Gossling?
Yeah.
Wait, I was on that set.
Okay, cool.
Oh, amazing.
Yeah, Sean Levy asked us to come visit, and we visited it for like a day.
What if you found out that Amy knew you were coming in?
She was like, this guy fucking called me once in the toilet at the White House.
This guy won't leave me alone.
I had a very small part.
Yeah.
You did.
Wait, are you a fan or no?
Oh, my gosh, yeah.
Yeah, huge.
Absolutely.
By the way, Tatooine.
I mean, amazing.
My Cat-A-Hat-Hat-on.
I love it.
I have my-Tat-Lead-Hat-on.
Do you go to May the Fourth Disney events at Disney?
Because I've always wanted to go.
Maybe next year you and I will figure it out.
Oh, my God, I would love it.
Leave the kids at home.
Am I right?
You're right.
I hate the May the Fourth be with you because that's my birthday.
That's Wilburne.
You're so lucky.
No, I'm not.
They took it over.
Everybody's like, May the Fourth.
I'm like, enough.
Wait, did you get to hold all the props
and whatever and all the fantasy stuff.
I love that.
Yeah, I went to the creature shop too.
Isn't that one?
Oh, cool.
I was so cool.
Watch the battles.
I saw the new, you know,
their version of R2D2 and the new one,
which I couldn't post.
We're not allowed to post.
Is he real?
We just racked focus.
There's Scotty in the back just heating up the paddles.
We're rubbing them together.
Getting them ready.
Oh, he's talking about the creatures.
your shop.
Charge!
Wasn't that?
But, and then the guy, I met the guy who created BV8.
Yeah.
That's wild.
It's so cool.
It's wild.
I mean, I'll talk about this, I'm sure, down the road, but like, I don't know what
I'm allowed to talk about, but I was so nervous the first day of working, like, I forgot
how to act.
I'm sure Sean Levy's like, Amy, are you okay?
And I'm like, no.
I'm just not okay.
You're just because of all the stuff that was around you and like, what were this?
No, just like, I'm on a Star Wars set.
I know, right?
Yeah.
I grew up on this.
This is like, I was like.
I have to now get out of my, like, dorky fan girl place
and go into, like, professional actress
and, like, combining the two was really hard.
So I had to, like...
Could you feel it?
Was it, was it palpable?
I mean, were the sets big?
Was the, what the camera gear, like, all, like...
It's so cool, you guys.
It's just so cool.
I'm, like, not allowed to talk about anything, of course,
but I can tell you, it's so cool.
And the kid in it is so great.
I just...
What about, what about, like, was there a lot of,
like were the sets real?
Were the weapons real?
Was it all like sort of green screens and, you know?
It's a mix, but it's...
A mix, yeah.
It was, it's enough to like get the feels.
You know what I mean?
And then you got the great Sean Levy there,
just like he's so infectious with his energy and enthusiasm
and his kindness.
And speaking of arrival, he was one of the producers on arrival.
He was?
Yeah, I worked with him at night at the museum.
Oh, that's crazy.
Yeah.
So you do the Star Wars,
and then you got another,
you got a sci-fi film
coming out later this year
that you did with our buddy Tyca.
What's that?
Right?
Yeah, yeah.
I was like I do.
I was like, yes, yes.
Yeah, we did that like over two years ago now, so yeah.
Wow.
Are you a sci-fi fan?
I do like sci-fi, yeah.
There's such a, you have, like,
so, like, Star Wars-y sci-fi.
Like, this is, like, seems to be the genre
that you're very comfortable in.
Superman.
Oh, I love it.
I love it.
Yeah.
But she's funny as hell, too.
And can sing and dance.
And we haven't even gotten to the drama part of it all.
I mean, I do.
I do love a good drama.
Do you want to leave any for anybody else?
Like, what's going on?
I mean, how great were you in doubt?
I saw that play and I was like, wow, this plays one of the best plays.
And then the movie with you and Meryl Streep and.
How good are Meryl and Philip in that?
Getting to sit through the rehearsals with them was, it's my entire actor training.
Like, I never went to college or conservatory.
So I really feel like that.
That was how I learned how to act.
And everybody showed up on set off book, probably.
Just nobody has side, right?
Everybody just knows their stuff.
Oh, yeah.
By that time, we really knew it.
Yeah.
I mean, it's Merrill.
Was it a lot of rehearsal for that film?
More than usual?
I would say so, yeah.
Yeah.
It was a while ago.
It was amazing.
So then, wait, did you just say that you did not go to drama school?
I did not, no.
No.
And so what would you attribute your,
your talent too?
Was it just a lonely childhood?
Yeah, how'd you get so talented?
A lonely childhood.
It's just like an innate, an innate sense of what would be...
I don't know. I think I've always just been,
I read a lot and I've always been plugged into characters and how and why and what motivates
them and all of that. And I think it just sort of started translating into acting.
I honestly, I also, when I moved to L.A., started working with
an acting coach
later on after I'd started working.
And that was really helpful
because she helped sort of ground me a bit more
instead of van very big.
So that was good.
Well, that's what I was going to say, yeah,
because theater is sort of at odds
with your incredible level of subtlety
when you're doing on-camera work.
You know what I mean?
It's just, it's just masterful
how little you have the discipline to do.
Which, you know, if you did that on stage,
the people in the front row would be able to read it,
but that'd be about it, you know?
Yeah.
I mean, it's great.
Thank you.
Oftentimes you'll see theater actors that are sometimes
maybe just a little bit bigger on screen.
Right.
But you do not suffer that at all.
It's really, really impressive.
Well, I absolutely love people's inner life.
Like, if I could know what people were thinking at all times,
I'd be so happy.
That's what I love about watching your performance.
It's like, yeah, I lean in and I try to read your mind.
You know, there's stuff going on inside as opposed to you.
You've got to watch this new doc that's coming out later this year.
I was telling Shawnee about it that's called,
this based on the podcast, that really popular podcast,
the telepathy tapes about the nonverbal.
There's a doc.
I just saw a screening of the dock.
Is it good?
It's unbelievable.
Wait, what is it?
Dude, this is a really popular podcast.
Yeah.
And called the telepathy tapes,
and they made a dock at the same time,
and it's coming out later this year.
And it's unbelievable.
I'd goosebumps the entire time watching it.
talking about people who can talk. It was real popular at the same time the Richard Simmons podcast.
Sean, stop mentioning the Richard Simmons. Every time I mention this, Sean brings up the Richard Simmons
podcast, I swear to God. Sean, why? No, how would that be? Leave it.
Leave it. Yeah, an easy reference for everyone. Yeah, let it stand on its own. Let it stand on
its own. Why do you have to mention the fucking Richard Simmons podcast every time? Because at that time
was years and years ago, those were the two most popular. I've never heard of it.
Richard Simmons podcast.
Oh, God, you would love it.
It's so wild.
Oh, here we go.
Oh, fucking fuck's sake, man.
Now, wait, Willie, the reason that you were seeing this earlier than when it's coming out
is because that makes me think maybe we're going to have somebody from it on the podcast coming up.
Did you get a little early link or something?
I don't know.
There's a guest coming.
Look at you putting some stuff together.
I used to be a cop.
I know.
Look at you.
Honestly, you guys, it's so fast.
fascinating.
And Amy,
talking about, like,
people understanding
what other people
are thinking and stuff.
It is a fucking mind-blower.
Did you listen to that, Amy?
Did you listen to that podcast?
Yeah, I did, actually.
I listened to,
I didn't get towards the end
of the telepathy.
It started to get,
I don't want to, you know,
it started to get a little,
like, it twisted a bit.
I don't want to give any spoilers.
Yeah, but it's,
it's, I found it.
I mean, it was just stunning,
and I'd listen to the podcast, too.
But anyway, yeah, yeah,
I don't know how we got here,
but boy, it's good.
It's really good.
So this is what I was going to say.
What was your first pro gig as an actor?
Your first paying job?
Like exclusively as an actor?
Does a dancer like...
As an actor, actor, actor.
What was your first...
Actor, actor.
I did a commercial for Omaha National Bank.
Okay.
Where I lip synced.
So I guess it's...
I mean, it's, I'm lip synced to summer loving, but turned into summer banking.
No, no.
Had me a blast.
Yeah.
Sure.
Summer banking, had me a blast.
Bo, bow.
Wow.
But then when I started, I was cast in Drop Dead Gorgeous out of Minnesota.
So that was like my first, like thing.
First thing.
And then what was your first, like, what was your first?
Did you do like a lot of, because I know, obviously you did Dr. Vegas.
We all know that.
We're talking about Rob Lowe.
I still call him Dr. Vegas.
Yeah.
What was your first, like, did you start doing guest spots on shows?
Oh, yeah, yeah.
Yeah?
I did all the guest spots.
I was on Charmed.
I was on Buffy.
I was on that 70 show.
Yeah.
West Wing.
Oh, wow.
We'll be right back.
And back to the show.
What was the point when you figured that you might be safe,
you might not need to have to study something else or have a second job or when did it, when did it seem yesterday?
You could make a living.
I think it was after, I think it was after Enchanted.
Yeah, because that was a big movie, yeah.
It's funny because by the time Enchanted came out, I'd been nominated, but I still didn't see that as like anything that cemented me as secure.
I just saw that as like an amazing, like one-off.
But having the box office of Enchanted, right?
That was a different thing with that, isn't it?
And I also think it was like the most confident at that point I'd ever been in a role.
Because even when I read the script, and I am not somebody who says this, I looked at my husband and went, I don't know who else are going to get for this.
Like, I just was like, no, no, no, no.
And I honestly, I'm not that person.
I would cast someone else in every role I've done.
Like, I'm not competitive like that.
But I read that one and was like, well, this is mine.
Just because I felt like I really understood that world and the duality of her.
But then you also do like, and then you go on to do a couple films with David O'Russell, some gritty films.
You do The Fighter, which is super gritty in such a great film.
Yeah, David, that was huge because David really, I say take a chance, but no one really saw me that way.
And then there was something about an interactive.
action he had with me that kind of was like, wait.
You got in his face about like a valet ticket or something.
You're terrifying.
No. No, I think he just...
I was here first.
Yeah, something like that.
Wait, was David, did you stab David O. Russell on the neck and then you and your dad saved him?
Is that what happened?
No, it was not David O. Russell.
So you were surprised when David called you with that?
Yeah.
Yeah, I was.
I was like to say, I have like such memories of where I was when things happened that were huge for me.
and I was in Ireland filming leap year,
like this romantic comedy,
which helped me learn that I was not good at romantic comedy,
though I loved the film.
I just was like, there are people who are really good at this,
and I don't think that's me.
I don't think...
There's nothing you're not good at.
Yeah, come on.
No, it's just, I'm too earnest.
Like, I want to turn it into, like, Wuthering Heights,
and, like, I just don't have that turn of phrase
that some people are so good at.
I'm just so earnest.
It's so irritating.
I've learned to accept it.
What about, what about, did your, did your eyes light up like mine would,
if I got a call from Paul Thomas Anderson?
Like, the master's one of my favorite, favorite films ever.
The master was great.
Paul is one of those people that I will forever want to impress.
It doesn't matter what I'm doing, what I'm saying, a text.
I am just, I just love him so much.
Just as a person, too.
Agreed.
Yeah.
I actually met him at a house party.
And I kind of ran the riot act because he had, he had, it's a lot, I don't want to get Paul in trouble, but he had.
He took the last piece of pizza.
No, no, there was a mutual friend that was a little drunk and acting, a little silly, and he was encouraging it, you know, having fun.
And I was like, that is highly irresponsible.
Now, to be fair, I was 10 weeks pregnant.
And I was not telling anybody.
So I was agitated.
And then I looked at there and I was like, I can't believe I just yelled it.
like my favorite filmmaker of all time.
I'm like, I'm never going to get to work with him.
I don't know what I've done.
But I was so like...
That's what it took.
And then I got Cass.
He's like, who can yell at Philip C.
Warholfman?
Who can be stern?
Who's that girl?
Wow.
I don't know if that's why he called me, but...
Oh, I just loved it.
He's so great.
Yeah, I still...
Anytime I hear from Paul, I'm excited.
But, yeah, he's wonderful.
So you do that.
I mean, and then you go, and then you jump into, like,
the, the, the, the, the, the, the,
world, the Zach Snydery's
sort of Superman, like that whole world.
Yeah.
It's amazing.
You just have all these like different like really distinct lanes
and stuff that you do totally so different.
Did you feel when you get that call?
You're like, yeah, yeah, this is something that I'm into.
No, again, I'm just super dorky and loved Superman.
So I was like, oh, I get to play Lois.
I was just, I grew up loving Superman.
Like I'm, I really, like, meant for Comic-Con like to go down there
in costume.
Like, that's...
Really?
Yeah, I love it.
I love jerky.
Darren's a d'or.
You've met my husband.
We're both just...
Dorky, earnest people.
Are you big Halloween?
Are you Halloween people?
Um, yes.
Sure, you are.
You bop around with Melissa and Ben
and you guys get all dolled up and do your thing.
That's different.
That was our movie club thing.
Right, but it's still, you guys...
Yeah, these guys, they'd watch a movie.
Yeah, oh, I do love a dress up.
I love a theme party.
I'm that girl.
Sure.
I have to, like, pull myself.
back if someone says theme party.
Darren's like, Amy, you don't have to be,
you can just have a suggestion of,
but I like that.
Ugly Christmas sweater party.
Yeah, it's sign you up, right?
Yeah.
I went to a 70s birthday party a few months ago.
I already had a dress in 1970s.
I remember that.
I was like, oh, we have to really go do it.
And then you go out kind of fun.
Yeah.
Well, luckily, Sean, you didn't have to buy a costume for that, right?
You just went into your wardrobe.
Yeah, Sean, what did you put together for that?
Yeah.
I put, I think my photos.
Hot shorts?
No, I put, bell bottom pants, a big wig, you know, some gold chains and some, you know, open, yeah, Anaboa.
All right, thank you.
It's got to get dressed too?
Yeah, we both did.
Let me just pick and find the picture.
I used to get dressed up for auditions, guys.
Like, I would go in costume, right?
Did you really?
Yeah, I didn't quite.
And then, like, other girls would be coming out looking absolutely beautiful.
And I would be like, oh, I guess I look like I want it too much, which is.
which is probably why I didn't work in the beginning.
I hadn't sort of cracked the code of neutrality.
I was like, it's me.
I don't know.
I feel like you did everything.
I have the pants.
I feel like you did everything really.
I think you did everything pretty damn well.
And then now,
your daughter doesn't,
does your daughter seem like she is attracted
to maybe going that direction too or no?
Not in performing.
And only recently,
on the set of Star Wars,
on our way to the creature shop,
she looked at me and said,
mom, do you think I could find a career in film?
Oh, wow.
And I said, yeah, absolutely.
And did you guys start to talk about different parts of it?
Yeah.
So we're constantly talking about different.
She's like, because I love travel.
I love meeting new people.
I like every day being different.
And this is really like the best suited job for everything I want my life to look like.
Right.
So, yeah, so she kind of switched her motivation.
She's still like really interested in psychology, like which I love.
So she and I are constantly talking about human behavior, which is fun with a 16-year-old.
But it actually is.
She's very intuitive and insightful.
Yeah.
So we'll see.
So isn't it neat how the conversations change over years?
Like, you know, like as much as you might miss the toddler age, it's like, well, you couldn't really talk about, you know, global issues.
Yeah.
Now you can get their take on that.
Yeah, because they're so involved now.
Yeah. I'm right. And they get so much, and they get so much information thrown at them too.
Yeah. I want to take her over to the groundlings to take a class because she's really quick-witted and mean.
And I'm like, hey, you're great in comedy.
Oh, we like that. We like that.
Mean like she's not a mean person, but like her wit is so biting.
Biting and sarcastic.
My husband's like, ow. And I just think it's when she, when she nails me, I laugh so hard.
It's really funny. So.
I love it. It's fun. It's fun. It's fun.
Speaking of psychological, you've got a psychological thriller series on Apple TV.
Dude, you're so good at bringing it back, Will.
I know.
I appreciate that.
It's been nominated.
Thank you.
I have not been nominated.
That's a skill.
Thank you, Amy.
You've been nominated in the group.
In the group, group, group, Amy, this.
Sean got singled out.
Sean one time got singled out as best host interviewer.
Of a podcast.
And he's part of a threesome.
Yeah.
They single him out.
He did not win.
I did not win, yeah.
Let me finish.
It's because I was held down by two others.
And I would say he's sloppy at best.
Contributive.
Oh, there they are.
There's a 70s.
Yeah, nice.
Oh, that's good.
I like you have hard copies, too, guys.
I know.
Scott had that.
That's beautiful.
So let's talk about Cape Fear for a little bit.
You and Javier Bardem, I mean, sick.
What a cast, Patrick Wilson.
Yeah.
My doppel gang.
Yeah, I was going to say you sort of look like his brother.
He and I, yeah.
We've taken selfies before and posted it.
Now, I was actually, I'm very cultured,
so I was watching PBS great performances last night.
And there was Patrick Wilson doing Rogers and Hammerstein.
Which one?
He's so good, you guys.
Like a medley of things along with a few other actors.
Sean, let's give us the number five, six, seven, eight.
Oh, God, there's a billion.
There's a billion.
But did you, did you, did you?
Did you and Patrick ever break out into song at all during some of the setups?
Okay.
So he's a little bit more disciplined than I am when it comes to the singing,
probably because he does it professionally,
and I do it because I just love it and it's fun.
So the first time he did sing, I thought I was being punked
because we were talking about some of our favorite concerts we've seen.
And I said, you know, oh, I went and saw the Indigo Girls in Red Rocks,
like 1992-93.
And it was such a good concert.
He's like, I love the Indigo Girls.
And I was like, you don't love the Indigo.
And he started singing like a deep cut from one of the albums.
And we harmonized for a bit.
And I was like.
And singing like a songbird, right?
Guys.
Yeah.
I was like, we're going to be best friends.
We're going to have so much fun.
We like the same things.
Put your number in my phone right now.
It was a lot.
But just, yeah.
I mean, all of us just talking about,
I feel like we're just, the closer we are to find,
you know what I mean?
Yes, exactly.
That's a deep cut.
But yes, Cape Fear.
Patrick's great.
Javier's great.
I mean, yeah, this one of, sick cast.
For it being so, like, challenging and difficult,
like content-wise and sort of the physicality,
it was so much fun.
And shot in Atlanta,
I shot with a lot of your crew from Ozark, I believe.
Yeah, I think.
They recovered?
They were able to recover.
Amanda Marsalis, I think, directed an episode or two, yeah?
She did too, yeah.
I just worked with her.
Yeah.
She's lovely.
Oh, we like Amanda.
She's really nice.
I like her.
Yeah, she was great.
No, I can't wait to see that show.
I've watched the trailer a couple of times.
It looks fantastic.
It does look like a lot of night shoots, which, you know, I'd have an issue with.
You know, but there's a lot of, a lot of nights shoots.
Or is it more splits?
Yeah, maybe we can just tent.
Honestly, it was a, it was challenging.
We couldn't block.
because we had a lot of directors, so it was challenging.
We could never block shoot.
So it was a lot.
It wasn't.
So for Tracy, Jamie, explain what block shooting means.
Yeah.
Jason, you do it.
You shoot out, like if all the scenes that take place in this one particular location,
no matter what episode they're in, we're going to shoot them all in a row so that we never
have to come back to this location.
She can knock out that location.
It's cheaper for budgetary reasons.
Right, right.
Yeah, when I did sharp objects, we did a lot of.
lot of block shooting and that was nice another great project i mean yeah okay i know it's amazing your
resume you're doing okay yeah you're doing okay you're doing all right jason you are you are you are at the
tip top of what you do you're so so good and everything you've never and we've talked about there
are very few people you're one of those people and we talk john goodman we hold up as the gold
center i always do have never a bad performance no matter what you do never a bad performance
There's still time.
No, no, Amy, you're so good, you're so talented.
Well, do you allow yourself to, this is a tough question to answer, but do you, do you have
more of her time than we're allowed, but go ahead.
Oh, shit, we are over.
Sorry.
You can cut a lot of my stuff out.
You guys are, no, no, no, we're going to let you go.
But do you allow yourself to sort of like say, hey, you know, I've done, I've done all right
and I'm like only halfway done.
And I thought maybe I was just going to, you know, kind of just sing and dance in front of mom and dad.
Don't say halfway.
That's because she's going to be exhausted.
No, but I mean, it's really, really impressive what you've done and what you will continue to do.
And you're still ascendant.
And I just, it's amazing.
Well, you know, I adore you.
And I'm just grateful.
I appreciate it.
Thank you.
I'm just grateful.
I think, like, I'm 51 now.
And I think being in my 50s is the greatest.
I'm so grounded and I just feel grateful and kind of open to whatever comes.
And grateful for.
what I've been able to do.
And it's a great time of reflection.
It shows.
You can, you see very comfy.
I will say, I think this is the longest I've ever talked to you because you're normally
ducking out of parties.
I know.
Oh, wow.
That doesn't sound like you.
So I'm so excited to get to talk to you.
It's something both these boys know, you know.
Yeah.
I go out and then it's time to go home.
No, you're smart.
Yeah, it's time to get into bed.
Like Jay always says, there's a window of energy.
And once that energy's up, that's it.
That's smart.
Well, I'm an introvert.
and also I don't drink anymore.
And so it's usually the last two hours at the party,
you've got to have a little in you.
Otherwise, the stuff that's being talked about
is just not that interesting.
Yeah.
And the stuff ain't that funny.
I'm usually the last person they are talking about that.
Not interesting.
That's like I know.
Can I top that out for you?
No, no, no.
Anymore, I'll be leaving at the same time.
I'm too tired.
I'm just tired.
Word to the wise,
if you run into Jason in a social setting,
Just make sure you have a bunch of stuff loaded
just to try to keep him interested
because he doesn't want to talk to you.
Sounds like a really great guy, doesn't he?
It's not true.
Self-involved asshole.
Jesus Christ, sometimes you do it for other people,
not just for you, you fucking dick.
God, you've had so much given to you.
You've had so much attention and shit given to your whole life.
Why don't you fucking give back to other people?
No bless oblige.
All right.
Let's ask some questions.
Amy Adams.
What a pleasure.
You're just a delight.
We love you.
You're so great.
And thank you so much.
We can't wait for Cape Fear on Apple TV.
It's fantastic.
And we just continued success.
You're just the great.
Thanks, guys.
Thanks for having me on.
I can talk to you guys for hours.
Likewise.
Hugs and kisses to Darren.
Yeah, to Amanda and the girls as well.
Thank you, honey.
Bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye, bye.
Bye, bye.
Bye.
Double A, right there.
I'm married to a AA.
Mandata, yeah, Amy Adams.
Yeah, that's right.
Two A's, two A's, two A's, two A's, double A.
And she's, what a career.
Every single thing you guys remember, I'm like, oh, that's right.
Oh, that's right. Oh, my God, that's right.
I mean, everything's quality.
Everything's quality.
Always.
And even if it's not, she's the best thing in it.
I mean, it's just, it never sucks.
No, that's what, that's a very, that's a rare, rare error.
Yeah, we all clank it every once in a while, but I don't, I think she's either buried the things that
she hasn't been good in or she's just never been bad.
Remember a night bitch?
Did you guys see night bitch?
I never saw it.
I saw the trailer
and I thought that
looks cool.
I like that moment
just looking at
I'm just pulled up
all of her stuff
because I'm like
I can't believe
it's awesome
Oh when you look at her
things
It's amazing
I was going to ask
what
musical she was in
she was into the woods
and in a 2013 interview magazine piece
she said she watched
Bye Bye Birdie with her dad
who's a huge
Ann Margaret fan
but she's never done that show
but it's a great title
Oh yeah
I was going to say, I'm surprised you didn't use bye-bye birdie for the goodbye,
but it sounds like you might be doubling back on that.
Well, it's one of those things.
Look, you know what?
He didn't, but everything happens for Eresas, you know?
You see?
Told you.
Well, there's a re-up coming Will's way.
You mean a Rees up.
You got it.
So if you haven't already, get out and bye!
Bye!
So, Rees!
Smart.
Smartless is 100% organic
and artisanly handcrafted by
Bennett Barbico, Michael Grant Terry, and Rob Armjarf.
Smartless.